alors pierre salinger vous êtes un tel
expert experts en tout en gastronomie en
politique on a envie de vous demander
votre avis sur tout alors quel est votre
avis sur le les élections sur le premier
tour le dimanche dernier ça vous a
choqué la les 14% de le pen elle et ils
ont surpris
ouais je pense que
je vous appelle monte avec une certaine
force ici en passe ouais et que
certainement il a fait beaucoup de peine
au côté conservateur des côtés baertschi
rap parce que monsieur chirac peut pas
gagner les élections sans les 14,4 pour
cent des voix de jean marie le pen
ouais et en analysant ça je vois très
difficilement comment il y aura c'est
quoi et comment vous comparez le
lepénisme primaire organismes primaire
différents
par exemple criant reagan a jamais dit
qu'on devrait jeter dehors tout
ici j'ai tout les avons d'ailleurs on
vient d'adopter une loi qu'il a est
soutenu dans laquelle on a fait de ces
immigrés il est garde des citoyens des
états unis particulièrement des
mexicains et les docks hispanique bien
quand même un conservatisme moral très
dur oui mais tu pense pas qu'on peut
faire une comparaison entre les gens à
terme il y avait un homme aux états unis
dans les années 50 qui s'applique
on était le gouverneur d'alabama louis
la changer sa politique plus tard mais à
cette époque on pouvait faire une
comparaison entre dubai world et jean
marie le pen n'a pas d'égal
qu'est ce qui va se passer aux états
unis alors s'écrit ce duke acquise
personne ne connaît ici moi non plus non
mais dukakis et trois fois gouverneur de
massachusetts près il a beaucoup
d'expérience en gérance en est à sa
seule faiblesse c'est qu'il a 5 ans
d'expérience dans les affaires
étrangères la défense pour moi ça c'est
ouais c'est difficile d'avoir un
président qui parle dans ces choses
vitales
alors si choisi un candidat pro
vice-président qui a des forces
par exemple il ya un sénateur de georgia
qui s'agace un jeune qui a besoin
d'experts sur la défense et des
étudiants alors là il peut bien se marie
pas seulement avec ce disque il est trés
parce qu'il n'est pas un sudiste mais
avec un homme qui pourrait apporter mais
son problème c'était assez taxe oui
c'est metz qui va le prendre comme un
numéro 2 ou non jesse jackson
vous savez au début de cette semaine
dans le
la revue newsweek ils ont publié un
sondage qui disait que dukakis avec
thaksin comme vice président pourrait
battre beau frère qui fait que du kaki
c'est un grand problème il le donne
la vice présidence ajaccio où il ne
donne pas s'il ne donne pas il va perdre
à mon avis ben 25 30% des voix noires et
pour un candidat démocrate c'est presque
fatal alors vous avez été très lié bien
entendu aux deux frères kennedy est très
ami avec bob rae porte parole de john
alors comme on vous tient là où on l
enquête sur dallas sur le crime de là
c'est ce que y'a plus lorsqu'il a avancé
il ya plus dans lequel maintenant il ya
tous les deux trois ans un nouveau livre
qui sort avec un nouveau beau mais pour
moi vous savez
j'ai jamais vu dans ses livres juste
dans ses enquêtes des preuves qui m'ont
convaincu
je garde encore dans ma tête quelque
chose que personne d'autre
gamesa c'est que john kennedy a été tué
par un fou ouais un homme qui était pas
partie d'un complot qui avait décidé de
le tuer et d'ailleurs c'était
intéressant parce que j'ai vu john kerry
pour la dernière fois le 19 novembre à
monsieur 4 jours 3 jours avant qu'il ait
été tué parce que moi je partirai au
japon pour commencer à préparer son
voyage va au début janvier 64 ouais et
j'avais aussi net cette journée là d'une
femme d'arras qui dit laisse pas le
président de niro parce que c'est très
dangereux ici va tuer et c'est vous qui
l'avez lu personnalisé de lettres et en
partant j'ai dit au président gilles
être bizarre d'une dame qui dit vous
devez parler parce que vous allez tuer
et dallas il m'a regardé il m'a dit vous
savez si quelqu'un veut qu un président
tout qu'il a besoin de donner sa propre
vie 26 g il avait pensé à ça il était
très au courant de la possibilité que
quelqu'un essaie de tuer alors va venir
en tout cas parce que la fréquentation
des hautes sphères de la politique vous
amène à écrire des romans avec la brosse
et alors j'ai remarqué une chose c'est
que pour la deuxième fois il lui avoue
quand il s'appelait le scoop où il y
avait un personnage qui s'appelait
albert tu call abricots et là vous
reprenez exactement la même le même
personnage est ce que c'est une volonté
comme ça d' inventer un personnage que
vous allez faire vivre deux romans
romans une haute idée quand on a
commencé à écrire c'est de faire trois
livres basé sur la personnalité de en
briques aux primaires comme vous avez vu
un journaliste américain
vieillissant et qui décide que
j'aimerais faire autre chose que le
journalisme mais qui plonge dans des
histoires tellement dur que dans ce
livre que vous avez vu on essaie de les
assassiner deux fois oui et c'est
pourquoi quelque chose se passe dans sa
vie il a besoin de dire qu'il est mort
même sa femme ses paquets qui n'est pas
morte et ont changé son identité à 100%
en chansons personnelles sa figure et
devient un autre personne y devient
pittsburgh
ouais et puis le bug qui est en brique
au versement à lenquête pouvoir qui a
essayé de tuer
andré cause alors nous on est tous là
vous vous travaillez toujours pas émis
si oui je suis encore chef des
correspondants à l'étranger
vous êtes états unis ont français basé à
new york nous aurions demandé de revenir
là bas ils m'ont demandé de me baser là
aussi pour qu'ils pouvaient utiliser
pour des conseils sur la politique
intérieure la couverture des choses
internationale mais j'ose rôle depuis
que je suis là je suis presque en de new
york tout le temps parce qu'il ya
également d'événements le monde entier
que je voyais sans cesse il ya eu
dernièrement un crack terrible dans
l'audience des détroits network
américain sont perdus chacun neuf points
10 points
alors on a accusé le
nouveau moyen de mesurer enfin l'audimat
américain a été modifié on a inventé un
système qui s'appelle people meet heures
est ce que vous croyez que c'est dû à ça
ou est ce que vous croyez que les
américains sont un peu là c'est comme ça
des séries américaines parce que
finalement dallas dynastie tout ça ça
marche plus tellement les usa lui si
vous habitez dans n'importe quelle
grande ville américaine
vous avez accès à 16 18 20 chaînes de
télévision et depuis que
les chaînes de télévision de câbles sont
installés depuis qu'il ya des films en
direct et sport en direct
il ya eu une baisse venant qui dure dix
ans
de la popularité des trois grandes
chaînes nt1 époque à 95% du marché et
qui maintenant aux alentours de 65 %
ils sont encore majoritaires mais ils
ont une concurrence énorme du côté du
câble vient vous voir la situation
française avec les petits combats entre
les petites chaînes françaises moi
j'étais toujours pour l'idée que des
chaînes privées en france
moi je pensais qu'il fallait avoir une
concurrence en se priver le public la
grande bretagne pour moi un exemple très
très bien cela le bbc qui était une
chaîne nationale qui était en train de
tomber qu'une fois en concurrence avec à
etienne a repris et venues des noms mais
bonne chance
la même chose
à mon ami aurait pu se passer une fois
aurait pu aurait pu mais à mon avis le
gouvernement très grande erreur de
privatiser la première chaîne il aurait
dû garder la première la deuxième comme
des stations d'état et laisser les
autres concurrents venir maison ils nous
regardent et qui ont une solide pour les
tares et c'est quoi votre ambition
pierre salinger maintenant c'est de
continuer à écrire des livres comme
l'année du faucon moi je referme aime le
travail des journalistes
parce que c'est quelque chose que je
fais depuis que j'ai 16 ans j'aime
couvrir le grand événement international
mais je vais continuer à lire à écrire
des livres aussi parce que vous savez
qui relie comme ça la raison pour
laquelle je fais c'est qu'un journaliste
en travaillant de la façon que je
travaille tombes sont des histoires où
il n'a pas de preuves et finalement quoi
faire avec toute cette information même
ce temps roman quand ça passe c'est vrai
ou faux et on va pas m'accuser de dire
des choses qui sont pas vraies
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou